- Is this everyone?
- Kaylan said he's going to be late.
- Okay, well we'll start without him.
I wanted to talk to you guys
about our toiletry campaigns.
- Hey.
Sorry, I don't want to interrupt the flow.
- Well, you did. Meeting ruined.
(laughter)
- Yeah, someone didn't get the memo!
- Yeah, I don't even think we can be
friends anymore, now, Kaylan.
- Yeah, Kaylan, you're fired.
(awkward laughter)
- That's a good joke, Natalie.
- Ah, nothing like a little
wholesome coworker ribbing.
So back to the toiletry campaigns...
Kaylan, what are you doing?
- Sitting down?
- I just fired you.
- You weren't serious?
- No, of course not.
Good one, Natalie!
Kaylan, sit down.
Just 'cause I'm the boss now,
doesn't mean we can't joke around
like when I was the receptionist.
- [Man on left] Hey,
can these go out today?
- It's too late! You're fired!
More candy? Fired.
- I've only got one package today.
- That's it, fired.
- I don't even work here.
- Not anymore.
- So you are joking, right?
- I, I think so.
- You think so?
- Honestly, I just was
joking around to seem cool,
but now I've fallen down
a sort of rabbit hole
and I'm not really sure
how to get out of the joke.
- Just stop.
We get it, it's cool. You did it!
- But, Kaylan, you
actually are on thin ice.
So maybe that's what
makes the joke so good.
A sort of funny-because-it's-true
type thing.
- It's not funny because
it's true though, right?
Because it's not true,
it's just a joke, right?
- What's funnier?
- Neither.
- Well, why does Kaylan's opinion matter,
because he doesn't work
here anymore, right?
- Do not keep feeding this, Elliot.
- Sorry.
- You don't have to do this, Natalie.
Just say, "Just kidding" and
we'll all pretend this didn't happen.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- But you guys would still
think I'm funny though, right?
- Yes.
- Of course.
- Absolutely!
- But not too funny, like you
would still take me seriously.
- Sure.
- Yes.
- Sweet Christ, yes.
- I'm so bored.
- Gotcha!
Kaylan, I was kidding,
sit down, we'll move on.
Ah, that was fun, back to
the toiletry campaigns.
I'm going to need all of
you to pick up the slack
now that Kaylan has been terminated.
- Good one, Natalie.
Pack your bags, Kaylan,
and if you have a badge, I'd like it.
(dramatic music)